hey y'all i'm sweaty shukla and for this
video i'm going to be inviting a tomboy
from texas to come check out my life in
la hi my name is chanel gaddis i live in
austin texas and i am a videographer for
this video i'm headed to los angeles
california to live life like my friend
swatsi shukla swatsi is definitely a
girly girl and i'm really a tomboy in
heart but i'm really looking forward to
doing whatever she has planned for me
i'm really nervous
but i'm excited
because i've never been to california
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man i'm so excited i just touched down
in l.a
hi guys i'm in my airbnb and i'm about
to get ready to make me some coffee
getting ready to go get my nails done
yay
first off you can't live a day in my
life without a fresh manicure i love
going to gru nail bar and my girl ella
hooks it up you don't have to go along
like me but definitely try something
colorful for a true la vibe
no i haven't had a manicure before first
time
i'm not really a girl girl usually more
of a
tomboy but this is something i can get
used to
[Music]
i might start getting my nails done more
often
[Music]
so yeah yo i just got my nails done
thank you swatzy my girl yeah
next head on over to woodland hills and
check out some bomb indian burritos at
the bombay frankie company
can i try your chicken tikka masala
i'm about to try a bunch of food i like
some choc and chicken
tikka masala
yeah it looks yummy
what's that a cucumber
what is this
it's good tasty let me see what this
chopped looking like i never had indian
food like this before
yeah that's good
that's the bomb
bombay
after you're done eating head over to
artesia aka little india be sure to
check out frontier heritage they have so
many beautiful south asian pieces of
clothing you can't go wrong with
anything there either and it's so fun to
just even window shop
[Music]
and this stuff is beautiful
sparkly shiny okay and i would love to
get my grandma's she could rock this in
the kitchen you know what i'm talking
about
i have not seen south asian clothing
like this this is extremely different
so i just left artesia it was really
awesome i enjoyed seeing the different
clothing i've never seen clothing like
that before
i'm glad my girl swasti told me to go
check that spot out next try doing some
yoga at everybody gym that is one of my
favorite ways to exercise i feel like i
really get to connect with my culture
that way
[Music]
hey
welcome to class how are you how you
doing my name is chanel just start to do
a body scan notice any tension
any tightness the next time you inhale
take your time filling up fill up as
much as you can
and then open your mouth and sigh it out
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you so much chanel
thank you
it's different
i feel good though okay
[Music]
that was like my first time trying out
yoga but i feel like i can
do it more often going forward
definitely i'm glad she told me about it
so
thank you swazi after yoga i want you to
try one of my favorite hobbies painting
i'll set everything up for you just let
the paint guide you and have so much fun
with this one i never paint at home
that's not my thing my daughter is the
artist in the family
i like to capture her moments
first of all it's very soothing very
common and i'm feeling all the vibes out
here yes lord
i'm just going with the flow because i
already know i can't think
i chose a sunflower because
it reminds me of the sunshine i believe
in life you have to live your best life
and
sean bright as you can i mean i feel
like i could say this in a museum or
something you know
i'm feeling it
so now that i swap lives with swasti i
feel like when i go back home i'll be
able to do more things such as getting
my nails done on a regular i probably
won't be as colorful but i might get
something solid you know whatever fits
my mood i'm ready and i'm excited to get
back home thank you so much for visiting
chanel you really take to the la
lifestyle i hope you had fun trying out
new things and you are welcome back in
cali anytime
so for this episode of bring me i
decided to invite one of my friends from
texas to experience la through my lens
take a look